darkness rises right hey everybody this
is gonna be my video all about the new
force powers that we learned people can
have during the last Jedi there's a
bunch of new abilities some of them are
pretty fantastic and some of the changes
to what we know about pre-existing lore
it broadens the mythology in certain
ways so certain people do things that
you didn't think that they would have
been able to do in previous movies based
on what we know about Star Wars so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet we will have to talk about
very specific character moments in the
film so if you haven't seen it there
will be spoilers in this video but if
you are finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's still going to be a lot of Star
Wars that we have to pick through
because it's a very divisive film that
has some very very big twists that
people will be talking about for a while
so as I'm posting this because the movie
just came out I'm still doing a ticket
giveaway I'll explain at the end of the
video let's just start with the Luke
stuff because that was some of the
biggest twists in the film and it
changes a little bit throughout so we
learned that he's cut himself off from
the force like he's been hiding out he
says he went to auch - to die why do you
think I came to the hardest place to
find in the galaxy so I saw a lot of
people being confused about what it
meant to close yourself off from the
force because this is an idea from the
expanded universe
he actually had a son with Mara Jade
called Ben Skywalker and part of their
story was as he was growing up he became
afraid of the force so he closed himself
off from it but what that means is when
they talk about the energy field that
binds all living things the energy
between the spaces in all things so it's
not like using the force to block the
force it's just like you're getting all
this information continuously from all
life in the galaxy and you just stop
listening to it cloaking yourself from
detection using the force is a slightly
different thing but the effect is the
same
like Leia has that special twin
connection with Luke and she has that
special connection with Han through the
force so she can sense the disturbance
in the force when they die but when Luke
has himself closed off it prevents Leia
from
detecting him so had he not closed
himself off Leia might have had an
easier time finding him but the really
big twist is what he projects his living
spirit across the galaxy in the best way
to describe it is by saying ghost dice
like how did the ghost dice work how was
he able to make that perpetual physical
form that lasts even after he brings his
spirit back to his body in the whole
idea with kylo Ren picking the dice up
and them disappearing in his hand is
that that's when Luke ascends to become
a force ghost so that effectively breaks
the connection is like the dice are an
extension of his will but the way they
used the ability in the movie makes him
seem kind of like a living holodeck he
projects his spirit but can also create
living form that can interact with other
things because the dice have physical
form and kylo Ren can hold them in his
hand and they clink like normal dice
would they make the sounds that normal
dice would he could have had a
lightsaber battle with kylo Ren on the
field so it's a pretty fantastic idea
like how is it that he can have physical
form but here's where it gets even more
interesting his feet do not leave
footprints on Krait surface so earlier
when they're all in the trenches and
that one person gets out and starts
walking along the surface it leaves a
red footprint when Luke is walking out
onto the battlefield his feet do not
leave footprints
yet his spirit and the ghost dice have
physical form so just let that blow your
mind and then we'll talk about force
ghosts because it's a slightly different
thing his force spirit is not the same
thing as the force ghost that you see
during the movie should you to give you
an idea for the scope of what he did
because projecting your force spirit is
a pretty big deal we're doing it over
such a great distance in the galaxy is
what taxed his body so much that he
wound up dying there were a lot of
people that pick through the original
map to Luke Skywalker that we saw during
force awakens in guest:that Ock 2 was in
the inner rim of the galaxy crate the
salt planet is in the outer rim of the
galaxy so even though you're not a
complete opposite ends of the galaxy
you're talking about a couple of
hyperspace jumps away that's how far it
is just a crazy crazy distance so
speaking of death talking about force
ghosts now so we know that force goes
just travel all over the galaxy is pure
energy so a lot of people are like well
if they can do that then wherever they
been this whole time so the whole idea
is is that they attain this level of
wisdom that's necessary to become forced
goes and in doing so they leave behind a
lot of the cares that they had while
they were alive so that's why Yoda gets
his sense of humor back from Empire
Strikes Back
Bob's Luke on the head and then gives
him some of these really big knowledge
bombs we are what they grow beyond
meaning the kylo Ren and Rey will learn
things that the Jedi that came before
them never thought about and I think the
force bond that they have between them
that telepathic bond is just the first
part of that they'll explore that
there'll be other new things that
they'll learn about the force but the
really cool thing is is when Yoda is
actually as a force ghost able to
interact with the living world which we
haven't seen before like we've seen
obi-wan Kenobi show up as a force ghost
and talked to people we saw Anakin Yoda
and obi-wan at the end of Return of the
Jedi show up and just stand there and
smile at everyone so during the film
when Yoda cackles with delight calls
down the lightning strike burning the
Jedi tree down you're like wait a minute
if they can interact with a living world
then what else can they do because even
though it's different than the Ghost
dice living force spirit that Luke
projects it's the same effect you can
actually reach out and Bop Luke
Skywalker on the head with your force
ghost cane and it makes a sound like it
actually makes the sound that would
would make if it were really bopping him
on the head so it might not seem like a
really big deal but it's a big change to
what we new force ghosts could do in the
past meaning that Luke Skywalker could
come back and Bop somebody on the head
with something but the next big ability
that we've never seen before is Leia's
force abilities so there was a little
bit of confusion but I think most people
understood what was happening when she
was sucked into the vacuum of space
for a full couple minutes but a normal
person would just freeze through and
completely die her body kicks into
survival mode and it's almost like the
force awakens her and protects her long
enough for her to regain consciousness
so that she can use the force to pull
herself back to the bulkhead and they
can let her in so when she's flying
through space that's just her using the
force to levitate
herself towards the ship so going back
years and years and years all the way to
Return of the Jedi the expanded universe
there were always versions of the Leia
character that were able to use the
force in certain ways but she never
completed the Jedi training she had
lightsabers but when she was using one
it was always someone else's lightsaber
they even did that in the comics for a
little while was pretty cool but what
they do with this film is just state
that she actually has more abilities
than you thought that she had so it
might not seem like a big deal but when
people say they expand the mythology
that's what they're talking about along
with the telepathic link because that's
a wholly new ability that we've never
seen before
at least on a level that we've not seen
before the connection between Luke and
Leia isn't quite that deep they can
sense each other but they can't see each
other like they're standing in the same
room they can't touch each other so you
have to remember that Ock too is in the
inner rim in kylo Ren is in the outer
rim chasing the resistance around so it
means that wherever rey goes with the
resistance in Episode nine even if
they're on the other side of the galaxy
from the first order in kylo Ren Rey and
kylo Ren will still have those
unexpected encounters in their mind
space but talking about those Jedi texts
that just mysteriously showed up on the
Falcon at the end of the film that's the
way for them to say that they're going
to be respecting the past and taking it
with them learning from it while they
forge new ground so Rey kylo Ren will
probably learn new things about the
force in the New Jedi Order whatever
that looks like in episodes 10 11 12
whatever the new Saga films wind up
being but even though you have Yoda
trolling everyone cackling with delight
burning down what's left of the old Jedi
he didn't really burn everything down so
Yoda is trolling everyone where he says
the girl has everything that she needs
because Yoda knows that the books are on
the Falcon so that's why he laughs so
much which is why I'm so happy with what
they did with the Yoda character a lot
of people didn't like the look but I
feel like thumb attica Lee the way they
used the character in the message that
he delivers is really good but let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite new force power during the film
and what do you think about the way they
broadened the idea of what we know force
ghosts are capable of there'll be a
whole bunch more Star Wars posting this
weekend I'll do an
straight videos sometimes Saturday or
Sunday just to give people more time to
watch the film but if you have any
special requests for Star Wars videos
just let me know in the comments below
there's a new round of the IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video congratulations to the winner from
my last video Darth Vader please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round when I
post new Star Wars click here for my top
10 WTF questions after the end of the
film and click here to learn all about
Disney buying Fox Avengers x-men
crossover stuff thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight